[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne
gellineck guten Abend heute ist Tag 5
nach dem Angriff der islamistischen
Hamas gegen Israel immer mehr Details
kommen ans Licht darüber mit welcher
kaltblötigkeit die palästinensischen
Terrorkommandos ihren Überfall geplant
und ausgeführt haben der israelische
Verteidigungsminister joaf galant zeigte
heute bei einem Treffen der NATO ein
schockierendes Video der Greueltaten an
israelischen Zivilisten die NATO der
Deutsche Bundestag samt Kanzler und die
USA sie alle bekräftigten heute dass sie
mit Wort und Tat an der Seite Israels
stehen und doch ist ist es ein schmaler
Grad israel habe jedes Recht sich
militärisch zu verteidigen müsse dabei
aber die Verhältnismäßigkeit beachten
übersetzt an die Zivilbevölkerung in
Gaza denken mahnen Verbündete die Sorge
dass sich der Konflikt zu einem Krieg in
der gesamten Region entwickelt wächst
Luk walport berichtet aus Tel
Aviv gedenken heute Abend im Zentrum von
Tel
aviv90 Kerz Erinnerung an die Opfer der
Hamas
Terrorattacken so viele junge Menschen
sind gestorben wir verstehen noch gar
nicht richtig was da eigentlich
geschehen ist und es ist noch nicht
vorbei schwere Tage auch für ihn
armeeschef Halevi muss seine Truppen auf
einen wahrscheinlich verlustreichen
Waffengang vorbereiten und schwere
Fehler
eingestehen wir sind für die Sicherheit
der Bürger Israels verantwortlich das
haben wir am Samstag morgen Gazastreifen
nicht
geschafft die Suche nach den Ursachen
muss warten der Aufmarsch an der Grenze
zum Gazastreifen ist wichtiger die
Mission Hamas soweit ausschalten dass
keine Gefahr mehr von den Terroristen
ausgeht alle hier wissen wie schwer das
wird auch in der Knesset ist jetzt nicht
die Zeit der politischen Aufarbeitung
Oppositionsführer ganz wurde heute als
Mitglied des kriegskabinetts vereidigt
begleitet von markigen Worten des
Regierungschefs
wir werden mit voller Härte gegen diese
verdammten Mörder diese Raubtiere
Vorgehen wir werden sie von der
Weltkarte
auslöschen was das heißt erfahren die 2
Millionen Bewohner des Gazastreifens
seit 5 Tagen unzäige Gebäude zerstört
mehr als 1000 Tote über 130 000
Obdachlose Leid und
Entsetzen unser Haus hatte sechs Etagen
gestern gingen wir schlafen dann stürzte
plötzlich das ganze Haus se sieben
Menschen sind jetzt tot und viele im
Krankenhaus ich weiß nicht wie es denen
geht und die Luftangriffe dauern an auch
heute
raketeneinschläge wie viele Menschen
hier in Gaza Hamas unterstützen aktiv in
der Terrorgruppe sind es schwer zu sagen
dass Hamas diese Vergeltungsschläge
durch die Terrorattacken provoziert hat
ist den meisten wohl klar eine
Möglichkeit ihr Schicksal zu ändern
haben sie kaum neben der Zerstörung
droht eine akute Versorgungskrise
es gibt kaum noch Brot dre Stunden musst
du anstehen wir versuchen es überall in
der Stadt aber es gibt kaum noch was zu
kaufen usaßenminister blinken sicherte
derweil den Partner Israel die volle
Unterstützung der USA zu noch während
der Gespräche meldeten Medien
israelischer raketeneinschläge in Syrien
an den Flughäfen Damaskus und Aleppo
wohl auch ein Signal in Richtung Teran
dem syrischen
Verbündeten
wir haben eine glasklare Warnung an alle
staatlichen und nichtstaatlichen Gegner
die glauben sie könnten die aktuelle
Krise für einen Angriff auf Israel
nutzen lassen Sie
es Israel hat die volle Unterstützung
der
USA anschließend traf blinken persönlich
mit Überlebenden der Hamas
Terrorattacken zusammen ein emotionaler
[Applaus]
Moment L walp ist unser Korrespondent in
Tel Aviv guten Abend es gab heute viel
Solidarität mit Israel aber auch
vorsichtige Mahnungen was die
Luftschläge gegen die Hamas in Gaza
angeht haben sie als Journalist die
Möglichkeit sich ein eigenes Bild davon
zu machen wie die Lage in Gaza im Moment
eigentlich
ist nein das ist sehr schwer wir haben
Kontakte natürlich wir haben auch
Mitarbeiter vor Ort auch die haben
keinen Gesamtüberblick
aber die Zerstörungen sind gewaltig das
Leid auch sehr groß das Problem ist eben
festzustellen aus der Ferne
äh Israel sagt es werden hamasziele
getroffen es ist natürlich sehr schwer
zu sagen wo Hamas ihre Kämpfer versteckt
wahrscheinlich sicherlich äh auch hinter
zivile Ziele äh sprich sie nutzen
möglicherweise Wohnhäuser wo sie sich
verstecken sie stellen Waffen oder
Raketenwerfer auf hintergebäuden
insofern sind das äh ja um zynisch äh in
der Militärsprache zu bleiben
Kollateralschäden aber die sind ebeno
gewaltig und da hat blink eben auch der
amerikanische Außenminister heute
sicherlich in den Gesprächen drauf
hingewirkt dass man aufpassen muss dass
das nicht zu einer Solidarität in der
gesamten arabischen Welt gegen Israel
und USA und damit zu einem Flächenbrand
führt das ist glaube ich die große Sorge
der Amerikaner und auch der Verbündeten
Israels mhm und wie kommen diese
Mahnungen der Verbündeten jetzt in
Israel an nach Verhältnismäßigkeit gibt
es angesichts der fürchterlichen
Verbrechen der Hamas überhaupt Raum
dafür in Israel über das Leid der
Zivilisten in Gaza und über die Folgen
einer möglichen Bodenoffensive überhaupt
nachzudenken es gibt diese Stimmen es
gibt auch hier in Israel Menschen die
sagen das kann jetzt nicht die Lösung
sein dass wir da 2 Millionen Zivilisten
in Gaza in dieser Form angreifen aber
zum einen sind die sehr vorsichtig
vorsichtig diese Stimmen und zum anderen
muss man einfach sagen die Emotion nach
diesen Terrorattacken vom Wochenende
sind hier in Israel soef der Schock so
tief dass das jetzt nicht der Moment ist
dass man über solche Dinge tiefergehend
diskutiert das ist auch nachvollziehbar
dankeelück nach
telaviv Israel war bis zum letzten
Wochenende ein beliebter
touristenhotspot wer letzte Woche noch
arglos in den Urlaub flog findet sich
jetzt in einem verwundeten Land wieder
die meisten internationalen
Fluggesellschaften haben den Verkehr aus
Sicherheitsgründen eingestellt auch die
Luft
hat ihre Linienflüge vorerst gcancelt
rund 5000 deutsche wollen nach Hause die
rückholflüge organisiert das Auswärtige
Amt es gibt viel Kritik bei denen die
noch warten und viel Erleichterung bei
jenen die am frühen Abend in Frankfurt
und München landeten Barbara Luk
berichtet Kerzen brennen schweigemine
tonnenschwere Stille gedenken für Israel
für die Opfer Freunde Verwandte das
Unfassbare aber da ist etwas das alle
eint Charlotte Knobloch Präsidentin der
Israelitischen Kultusgemeinde in München
ringt um Fassung um Worte es scheint als
Ringe sie um alles als Präsidentin als
Jüdin als
Urgroßmutter ich habe meine Enkelin
gebeten sie soll mit ihren Kindern doch
kommen sie hat gesagt
nein gestern hat sie mich angerufen sie
muss kommen die Kinder halten das nicht
aus zeitgleich am Münchner Flughafen
Angehörige warten seit Tagen warten Sie
Jann Lippert ist aus Dresden angereist
ihr Mann und ihr Sohn haben den
Patenonkel in Israel besucht dann das
Wiedersehen wir haben eigentlich auch
schon oft gegeben gehabt über die
Botschaft was zu machen und waren schon
auf dem Weg nach Jordanien selber aber
im Endeffekt hat's dann doch noch
geklappt aufatmen auch bei den
Jugendlichen die einen freiwilligen
Dienst in Israel absolvierten wir haben
gestern sehr lange gebraucht um die
Flügel zu buchen und deswegen es ist
jetzt eine Erleichterung hier zu sein
hallo danke dass ihr die flügeel gebucht
hab wirklich sehr aufreibend es war ein
großes Durcheinander weil wir kommen aus
Tel Aviv und es war immer wieder so dass
immer wieder viele Raketen gekommen sind
viele Alarmen auch am Frankfurter
Flughafen brechen die Dämme Ankunft
Heimkehr Menschen ohne Worte liegen sich
in den Armen
Gemeinschaft die Frau von mir fragte
sind wir außer von raketenreichweite
weil das war die Angst nachdem sagen wir
mal Fiasko dieser organisatorischen
Ausreise also es ist schön wieder hier
zu sein mich der gefolle ne so ich
wollte hier nicht wirklich kommen ich
wollte in meine Land bleiben aber der
jetzige Zustand ist einfach
schrecklich alle suchen alle brauchen
Hoffnung auch an diesem Tag am Flughafen
vor der Synagoge in München und da ist
etwas
das alle
[Musik]
ein so etwas erleben
Hauptstadtjournalisten selten im
Bundestag klatschten heute Abgeordnete
der Opposition bei der Rede des Kanzlers
und alle Fraktionen also die der
Regierung und die der Opposition
einschließlich der AFD stimmten
gemeinsam für eine politische Erklärung
in der sich alle Parlamentarier an die
Seite Israel stellten zumindest 90
Minuten lang schien die Spaltung des
Bundestags aufgehoben über eine
besondere Debatte in Berlin berichtet
Dorte
Ferber der Bundestag in seltener
Einigkeit an diesem Morgen den
israelischen Botschafter empfangen Sie
hier alle mit starkem Applaus einstimmig
beschließen die Abgeordneten deutschland
müsse alles Notwendige und er wünschte
zur Selbstverteidigung Israels zur
Verfügung stellen israel habe das Recht
zur Selbstverteidigung in diesem Moment
gibt es für Deutschland nur einen Platz
den Platz an der Seite Israels das
meinen wir wenn wir sagen die Sicherheit
Israels ist deutsche
Staatsraison dann erklärt Scholz
Staatsraison in der Praxis ein Verbot
der Hamas und der radikalen Organisation
samidun in Deutschland z.B oder
Diplomatie man spreche eben mit denen
die Einfluss im Konflikt haben Ägypten
der Türkei und Katar den
Kritikern solcher Kontakte und der
Tatsache dass wir sprechen sage ich es
wäre
unverantwortlich in dieser dramatischen
Lage nicht alle Kontakte zu nutzen die
helfen können fast alle die heute ans
Kult gehen äußern sich empört über Hass
und Hetze auf deutschen Straßen die
Union wolle beim Kampf gegen
Antisemitismus unterstützen bietet
Oppositionsführer März dem Kanzler an
und dazu zählt
auch das haben sie dankenswerterweise
erwähnt dass wir alle Zahlungen an die
palästinensischen Gebiete und
Organisationen auf den Prüfstand stellen
unser Maßstab muss dabei klar sein wer
Israel vernichten will oder den
Holocaust verhamlost der darf kein
deutsches
Steuergelden die AFD mutmaßt das
entwicklungshilfegeld missbraucht werde
dass ein Teil dieser Raketen ein Teil
dieser von der Hamas eingesetzten Waffen
womöglich mit deutschen Steuergeldern
bezahlt wurde ist ein unglaublicher
Skandal und DIE LINKE fordert eine
Änderung der
Iranpolitik wir müssen aufhören wissen
und Technologie an den Iran zu
exportieren denn die Ingenieure hinter
den Hamas Bomben haben ihr nohau aus dem
Iran kein Streit im Plenum heute Partei
übergreifend wird die Gewalt der Hamas
verurteilt ich erwarte
auch von muslimischen Verbänden in
Deutschland eine klare Haltung und
Distanzierung vom schrecklichen Terror
der Hammers es geht nicht darum dass
zwei Streitparteien da gerade im Gange
sind es geht um einen demokratischen
Staat der sich WRT gegen blanken Terror
deshalb gibt es keine equidistanz zu
niemanden wir stehen nur an der Seite
Israels an der Seite Israels und vor
schwierigen Gesprächen Olaf Scholz
empfängt im Anschluss den Emir von Qatar
das Land gilt als Geldgeber der Hamas
nun soll der Emir bei der Freilassung
der Geiseln vermitteln her Bundeskanzler
der Besuch des Emir von Qatar in Berlin
war schon lange vor dem letzten
Wochenende verabredet das schwerreiche
Herrscherhaus soll Deutschland LNG
verflüssigtes Gas liefern damit die
Bundesregierung kein Gas mehr in
Russland kaufen muss der Emir von Qatar
ist aber auch einer der Hauptfinanziers
des islamistischen Terrors z.B der Hamas
fragen wir nach in Berlin bei unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Diana
Zimmermann Diana das Mittagessen des
Bundeskanzler mit dem emier von Qatar
der ja immerhin die Führung der Hamas in
Doha beherbcht hat sehr viel Kritik
ausgelöst warum hat Scholz ihn nicht
einfach ausgeladen in dieser
Situation es muss wohl Hoffnung gewesen
sein Olaf Scholz hofft dass der EM sich
bei der Hamas für die Freilassung der
150 Geiseln darunter fünf deutsche
einsetzt dafür ist der
in einer günstigen Position denn Qatar
ist einer der wichtigsten Unterstützer
der Hamas dazu passt dass Qatar die
Verantwortung für die Terroranschläge
der Hamas ganz bei israel sieht Grund
sein Zitat die ständigen Verletzungen
der Rechte des palästinensischen Volkes
Museen des Landes waren gestern in den
Farben des palästinensischen der
palästinensischen Flagge angeleuchtet da
könnte der Unterschied zu Deutschland wo
Israel Flaggen vor Regierungsgebäuden
gehisst wurden und wo der Kanzler heute
morgen wieder von unverbrüchlicher
Solidarität mit Israel sprach kaum
deutlicher sein aber Katar hat den Staat
Israel anerkannt unpflegt enge
geheimdienstliche Kontakte mit Israel
und es sieht sich als Vermittler in dem
Konflikt zwischen Israel und der Hamas
und so hat Scholz dem mitgegeben dass er
die sofortige Freilassung der Geiseln
fordert und dass die Verantwortung für
die Geiseln allein bei der hammersliga
es gab nach dem Treffen der beiden keine
PK dafür aber die Absichtserklärung man
wolle in engem Kontakt bleiben und
welches Interesse hat jetzt Kat an der
Vermittlung um die geisn zu befreien Kat
spielt sehr häufig den Vermittler z.B
auch zwischen den USA und den Taliban
sich außenpolitisch ganz breit
aufzustellen das war schon historisch
eine Sicherheitsstrategie in diesem
kleinen Land und heute sieht das konkret
so aus dass die USA ihre größte
Militärbasis in der Region in Kater
haben und eben die Führer der Hamas dort
leben das Land enge wirtschaftliche
Beziehung zu Asien insbesondere China
pflegt Gas an uns verkauft und auch wenn
das hier anders diskutiert wurde war die
fußballwm für den emia ein Triumph im
Inland und besonders im arabischen
Ausland es ist ihm gelungen die
regionale Bedeutung qatars auszuweiten
und der Erfolg gibt im Recht die USA
haben Kat schon am Samstag um
Vermittlung in der geiselfrage gebeten
und auch Außenminister blinken sagt dem
ier keineswegs ab sondern reist morgen
von Israel nach Doha also Bemühungen auf
allen Seiten danke Diana nach
Berlin und wir machen hier weiter mit
den Nachrichten und Hanna Zimmermann und
da geht's noch mal um das natotreffen
heute in Brüssel ja ganz genau denn dort
hat die NATO Israel neben Solidarität
auch konkrete militärische Hilfe
versprochen Deutschland will Israel mit
zwei Kampfdrohnen unterstützen geprüft
wird außerdem die Lieferung von Munition
für Kriegsschiffe und auch die Bedrohung
durch Russland war Thema des Treffens
für die neue abschreckungsstrategie der
NATO will Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius künftig 35.000 Soldaten in
sehr hoher Bereitschaft
halten bei der Verkehrsministerkonferenz
haben Bund und Länder keine Einigung
über die weitere Finanzierung des
deutschlandstickets erzielen können die
Länder hatten angek t auch ab 2025 die
Hälfte der erwarteten Mehrkosten für das
Ticket zu übernehmen und fordern dies
auch vom Bund dieser lehnt dagegen eine
Finanzierung von Zusatzkosten ab auch
bei der heute gestarteten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz soll es um
das deutschlandticket Gehen Hauptthema
ist allerdings die
Asylpolitik innerhalb der organisierten
Kriminalität in Deutschland steigt die
Gewaltbereitschaft das zeigt das heute
vorgestellte Lagebild für 202
laut Bundeskriminalamt sind kriminelle
Banden zunehmend bereit mit teils
drastischen Mitteln ihre Macht zu
demonstrieren erfasst wurden 16
vollendete und 22 versuchte
Tötungsdelikte der Schaden durch
Rauschgifthandel Wirtschaftskriminalität
und Geldwäsche wird auf 1,3 Milliarden
Euro
beziffert vier Tage nach der
Landtagswahl in Bayern haben sich CSU
und Freie Wähler auf die Aufnahme von
koalitionsverhandlung geeinigt morgen
sollen sie starten und zwar mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit das gaben beide Parteien
nach einem ersten Sondierungsgespräch
bekannt bereits vereinbart sei sich
gemeinsam strickt von der AFD
abzugrenzen die war bei der Wahl hinter
CSU und Freien Wählern auf Platz 3
gelandet der Wolf lebt gern in
Deutschland jedenfalls vermehrt er sich
munter nach neuesten Zählungen aus den
Jahren 22 und 23 gibt es inzwischen 184
Wolfs Rudel und 47 Wolfs Paare das wäre
eine gute Nachricht wenn der Wolf nicht
täte was Wölfe nun mal tun nämlich
andere Tiere fressen eigentlich ernähren
sich Wölfe von wild aber immer öfter
reißen sie auch Nutztiere wie Schafe der
Streit zwischen Tierschützern und Bauern
schwäht schon lange heute hat die
Bundesumweltministerin neue Vorschläge
gemacht die den Abschuss von Wölfen
erleichtern könnten senenja Domeier
berichtet er ist wieder heimisch in
deutschen Wäldern nach Jahrhunderte
langer Verfolgung galt der Wolf als
ausgerottet bis ein strenger Schutz die
Bestände wieder wachsen ließ inzwischen
reißt das Raubtier immer häufiger
Nutztiere wie die Schafe von Silvia
Krause ihr 1,10 hoher Schutzzaun half
nicht dreimal hat der Wolf dieses Jahr
schon Tiere aus ihrer Herde getötet es
ist ja nicht das erste Mal also dass mir
das passiert ist also mein Schafen
passiert ist innerhalb der letzten 10
Jahre war das jetzt dieses Jahr bis
jetzt der neunte Übergriff ne seit gut
20 Jahren gibt es immer mehr Wölfe etwa
184 rudelstreifen derzeit vor allem
durch Deutschlands Nordosten weil mit
ihrer Anzahl auch die Probleme steigen
soll der Abschuss einzelner Tiere jetzt
leichter werden konkret bereits nach dem
ersten Riss können Wölfe 21 Tage lang im
Kreis von 1000 m von der betreffenden
weideer ohne dnatest geschossen werden
das gilt in Regionen mit erhöhtem
rissvorkommen der Wolf muss eine
zumutbare
herdenschutzmaßnahme überwunden haben
aber einmalig überwunden haben nicht
mehrfach immerhin auch in Zukunft keine
pauschale Bejagung von Wölfen lobt der
Naturschutzbund sieht Abschüsse aber
generell skeptisch weil geschwächte
leichte Beute wie Nutztiere sogar eher
suchen könnten wenn ich sogar anfange in
Rudeln rumzuschießen also einzelne Tiere
zu entnehmen da habe ich sogar eventuell
Effekte dass sie verstärkt auf Nutztiere
gehen wir sehen das an Beispielen in
Frankreich die deutlich weniger Wölfe
als in Deutschland haben und viel viel
mehr Risse die haben eine Quote
eingeführt und das wirkt halt überhaupt
nicht dem Bauernverband geht Lemkes
Entwurf nicht weit genug mit solchen
placebolösungen wird die weidetier
weiterhin einer verfehlten und
weltfremden wolfspolitik geopfert
Landwirt und Pferdezüchter Jürgen Rump
wünscht sich das Abschüsse auffälliger
wörfe schnell möglich werden in seiner
Nachbarschaft wurden schon fünf Pferde
gerissen sein Fohlen stellt er nur noch
dicht ans Haus bei dem Schäfer dort
hinten auf der Schafherde haben die
Wölfe innerhalb der letzten Jahre über
100 Schafe gerissen und dann weiß man
auch wie nah der Wolf ist ob der nun 5
km oder 10 km entfernt ist heute heute
hier morgen da
zur nächsten Weidesaison sollen die
Vorschläge in Kraft treten offen bleibt
ob sie den Konflikt zwischen
weidetierhaltern und wolfsschützern
nachhaltig
lösen und wir machen hier weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und Hanna
Zimmermann und da blicken wir auf Zahlen
die heute durchaus aufrchen lassen es
geht um die Finanzhilfen der
Bundesregierung die sich in diesem Jahr
laut einer neuen Studie mehr als
verdoppeln werden auf 208 Milliarden
Euro Frank betmann das ist ein massiver
Anstieg und als Grund wird die
Energiekrise genannt ja infolge des
ukrainekrieges der Bundeshaushalt ist
geprägt von dem Bemühen die Folgen für
die Verbraucher und Unternehmen zu
dämpfen die größten Posten der für
dieses Jahr geplanten Finanzhilfen sind
demnach die Ausgaben für die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse dafür allein werden aus
dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond
voraussichtlich über 80 Milliarden Euro
zur Verfügung gestellt und damit mehr
als der Bund und noch 2021 insgesamt an
Finanzhilfen gewerte von 98 Milliarden
Euro im vergangenen Jahr könnten die
Unterstützungsgelder laut IfW nun auf
208 Milliarden Euro steigen angesichts
von Ausmaß und Bedeutung der
Energiekrise für das soziale
Zusammenleben im Land ist ein Anstieg
der Finanzhilfen zu erwarten und
nachvollziehbar aber dieses enorme
Ausmaß springt den bislang gekannten
Rahmen sagt Klaus Friedrich Laser
subventionsexperte beim Institut für
Weltwirtschaft Kiel offen allerdings ist
ob die Hilfen des Bundes auch wirklich
in dieser Höhe ausfallen werden die
Mittel für die Strom- und gaspreisbremse
sind noch längst nicht ausgeschöpft
vielen Dank Frank für diese
Einordnungen das Internationale
Olympische Komitee hat Russland aus dem
internationalen Dachverband
ausgeschlossen dies sei geschehen weil
die russische Seite Regionalverbände aus
vier annektierten ukrainischen Gebieten
aufgenommen habe das sei ein Bruch der
olympischen Karter so das IOC weiterhin
ungeklärt ist dagegen die Frage ob bei
den Sommerspielen 2024 russische
Sportlerinnen und Sportler teilnehmen
dürfen die eichendorfschule in Erlangen
ist heute mit dem Deutschen Schulpreis
ausgezeichnet worden der Hauptpreis der
mit 100.000 € dotiert ist wurde von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier überreicht
die Jury lobte die bayerische
Mittelschule für für ihr pädagogisches
Konzept sie setze etwa auf lernlabore um
ihren Schülern die Angst vor Fächern zu
nehmen und ihnen Freude am Lernen zu
vermitteln und zum Schluss zu einer
Ausstellung die genauso monumental ist
wie der Ort an dem sie stattfindet die
Geschichte des deutschen Films gezeigt
in der Völklinger Hütte dem riesigen
Eisenwerk im saarand das längst
Weltkulturerbe ist in der historischen
gebläserhalle eine Schau vom deutschen
Stummfilm bis hin zu legendären
oscargewinnern von
1895 bis jetzt ab diesem Samstag ist die
Ausstellung für uns alle zu sehen
Susanne Freitag carteron durfte heute
schon mal gucken wie Filmindustrie auf
Industriekultur
trifft die ersten bewegten Bilder wurden
noch
angekurbelt das war dann die erste
Kinovorführung der Welt im Berliner
wintergartentheater
1895 und schon 1919 gab es Deutschlands
ersten weiblichen Stummfilmstar Asta
Nielsen ihre Filme wurden weltweit
vermarktet lange bevor es Netflix
gab an der Decke hängt der Vorläufer der
heutigen GoPro len Riefenstahl schnallte
sie 1931 auf Schia für den Film der
weiße Rausch auf riesigen Leinwänden
Flimmern 128 Jahre deutsche
Filmgeschichte erster Weltkrieg zweiter
Weltkrieg Wirtschaftswunder
Wiedervereinigung vorher noch Ost und
West Ufer und defer das ist wirklich
ganz wunderbar dass wir diese ganze Zeit
so auf den Punkt bringen können mit
einer Kunstform nämlich mit dem
Film Monument der Filmgeschichte
Metropolis von Fritz
Lang hier stehen die originalmasken
Kostüme Dokumente der filmst
1927 von Kritikern zerrissen erst
gekürzt dann mühsam rekonstruiert heute
Kult und Referenz Ridley Scott klaute
kräftig für Blade Runner der inzwischen
selbst zum Kultfilm wurde und auch Ghost
in the Shell japanischer Cyberpunk ist
Metropolis inspiriert wir haben so viel
Mühe auf diesen Film und nicht nur wir
sondern Filmarchive international haben
notgedrungen weil er so verstümmelt war
so viel Mühe auf diesen Film verwendet
wir zeigen dass es sich gelohnt hat weil
dieser Film tatsächlich
Ausstrahlungskraft
hatte der Blaue Engel machte Marlene
Diedrich zu Ikon nicht nur der Film
sorgte für einen Skandal sondern auch
dieser Hosenanzug den man damals als
Frau noch nicht zu tragen hatte das
Spiel mit den Geschlechterrollen
Homosexualität Quere Themen ziehen sich
durch die filmepochen rosa von
Frauenheim brach in den 1970ern
lst uns schwuler werden aber er war
nicht der erste das ist das nachgebaute
Filmset von Mädchen in Uniform
1958 küssten sich hier Lilli Palmer und
Romi Schneider wir beginnen ja schon
früh mit dem Hinweis darauf dass Quere
Themen im deutschen Film nicht erst nach
197 aufgetaucht sind sondern schon 1919
das erste Mal oder auch 1917 schon und
insofern ist es auch eine Vollendung der
inhlichen ichte die hier erzählt wird
die neueren Werke beklemmend aktuell wie
das preisgekrönte Kriegsdrama im Westen
nichts
Neues die Ausstellung ist ein Run durch
die
Epoche ein gigantisches Multimedia
Spektakel in historischer
Industriekulisse ganz großes Kino auf 80
me gehen auf 80 me gehen
langsam und das war von
uns diskutiert hier gleich weiter Titel
ihrer Sendung Terrorangriff auf Israel
uneingeschränkte Solidarität zu Gast
sind unter anderem Annalena berbock
Armin laschett und der
terrorismusexperte peter
Neumann und später gibt's dann noch
unser heute journal Update gegen 0:30
Uhr mit Christopher wermann und uns
gibt's morgen wieder einen schönen Abend
und Tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen liegt ein sturmtie
vor Skandinavien und es gibt da wirklich
viel Wind vor allen Dingen hier
südöstlich von Island das sehen Sie an
der drängung der Isobaren der Linien
gleichen Luftdrucks aber auch bei uns
gibt's morgen viel Wind viel Regen und
viel Wärme heute Nacht regnet es noch
leicht und es bleibt noch m die
Temperaturen sinken auf 16 bis 10° im
Nordosten wird es bei 9 bis 6° schon
kälter und morgen breitet sich der Regen
aus am Vormittag geht das Los hier über
nordrehein-westfalen dann auch in
Niedersachsen Bremen Hamburg schäig
Holstein meckelenburg Vorpommern
SachsenAnhalt und Brandenburg Feld Regen
dann beruhigt sich die Lage kurz zum
späten Nachmittag und Abend drohen dann
kräftige Schauer zum Teil auch Gewitter
von Nordwesten dazu gibt es schwere
sturmböhnen an der Küste und auf dem
Brocken im Harz vielleicht sogar
orkanböhnen von all dem bekommen sie
ganz im Süden nichts mit da strahlt die
Sonne und so sind rekordverdächtige
Temperaturen bis 30° mit föne am
Alpenrand oder auch im Breisgau möglich
auch sonst ist es mild bis warm mit 18
bis 26°. diese 30° werden uns dann aber
verlassen sie ziehen hier nach Osten ab
und kalte Luft flutet Mitteleuropa diese
10° erreichen bis Montag auch
Ungarn der Samstag wird ein sehr
wechselhafter Tag am Sonntag kann es im
Erzgebirge oberhalb von 800 m für Einzel
Schneeflocken reichen am Montag
beschränken sich einige Regenschauer auf
den Nordosten schönen Abend